in this video we'll talk about
site-specific recombination as the name
suggests
the site or a specific part of the DNA
is crucial for these kind of
recombination reaction
so this kind of recombination reaction
just like any other recombination
reaction needs certain degree of
homology between two sequences
but unlike other recombination reaction
these recombination reactions are site
directed and orientation of the sites
matter
it leads to integration of a DNA
fragment into a Target sequence
ultimately site specific recombination
is highly specific fast and efficient
let's talk about some outcomes of the
site-specific recombination
there could be many outcomes like
insertion of a DNA sequence into a
Target region in this case the red
sequence is getting integrated into that
green region
and notice that there is a certain
degree of orientation that is maintained
in this recombination reaction
there could be other outcomes such as
deletion
so this red sequence is the part of this
entire region
but
due to some particular orientation
this sequence can be fluxed out or moved
out of these region and deleted
there could be also
inversion that means you can see these
sequences in a form of A and B
and due to inversion their orientation
can be changed
and all of these can possibly happen
now let's talk about the enzymes that
leads to this kind of site-specific
recombination the key enzyme that plays
a vital role in this kind of
recombination process is known as height
specific recombinase
now any recombination recombinase enzyme
would have some kind of like
nucleophilic Center
most of the cases they are either serine
or tyrosine so there are two types of
site specific recombinants serine
recombinations which has serine in their
active site
and tyrosine recombinase which has
tyrosine in their active site
so let's understand that how
site-specific recombination reaction
works so here you can see a segment of
the DNA
now this is the site-specific
recombinence which has the serenity
anyway it has that nucleophil from the
hydroxyl group it would attack in the
phosphate backbone and this results in
creation of a enzyme DNA complex
eventually
uh this kind of complexes would be
required
to carry the reaction forward
now let us try to take help of some
block diagrams to understand this
process better so first let's talk about
how serine recombinase works so serine
recombinases
lead to formation of DNA breaks
and
serine recombinations
form this kind of phosphate DNA hybrid
with one strand
now eventually what happens
these strands get passed
and ultimately resealed
to form
the overall
integrated sequence now here you can see
the recombination is complete
tyrosine recombinence is bit different
from Serene recombinence here uh one
strand at a time is taken care of that
means the breakage of two strand doesn't
happen simultaneously tyrosine
recombinants forms those enzyme DNA
complex
for one stand only in this case the
upper strand
exchange happens for only one strand
right now eventually the second strand
is also exchanged and the recombination
process is complete now this is the
fundamental differences between serine
recombinants versus tyrosine recombinase
the outcome is same but the way the
outcome is achieved is different let's
talk about some biological examples of
site-specific recombination
Lambda phage genomic integration into E
coli is one of the example of site
specifically combination you know that
fudge actually uh injects its genome
into the E coli and in case of Lambda
Fage The genome gets integrated into the
E coli genome there are certain site in
the
fade genome known as attp sites and
there are certain sites in bacterial
genome known as ATT B sites these sites
recombine with each other
and with the help of integrase enzyme
which is an example of tyrosine
recombinase enzyme and that leads to
integration of the phage DNA into the E
coli genome
now other examples can be obtained from
the hin recombinase mediated DNA
inversion in salmonella in Salmonella
bacteria there are two kinds of flagella
each one flagella and H2 flagella now
hin recombinase based example is a great
great example of how these flagellar
gene expression can be modulated by side
directed recombination
so our region known as Hing give rise to
hin recombinants which is capable of
Performing site directed recombination
and there are two important
recombination size sites known as hex L
and Hicks are
now there is a promoter adjacent to
Hicks R which controls the expression of
fish b and fidge a gene which P Gene
give rise to H2 flagellin which is an
important flagellar protein and
determine which type of flagella the
bacteria would have and which a give
rise to H1 Flagyl in repressor this
repressor blocks the expression of H1
flagellin and ensuring that particular
bacteria would gain a H2 flagellin
containing a protein
now due to this hin recombinant mediated
site directed inversion
the overall orientation of the hin
recombinase and the promoter site can be
altered now you can look at the promoter
and the Henry communities you can
appreciate the orientation is inverted
right now
now as a result the fridge B and fridge
a genes are very far apart from the
promoter region they cannot be regulated
by this promoter
that is why H2 flagellin and H1 Flagyl
in repressor are not produced
so by default H1 flagylene is the key
molecule right now
so right now we can see just by changing
the
sequence orientation early which leads
to inversion
the bacteria can decide whether to
express H2 flagellin or H1 flagyling and
this is a great example how site
directed recombination recombination can
regulate a transcriptional outcome or
fate outcome of an organism
now let us talk about the biomedical
applications of site-specific
recombination the lessons that are
learned from biology are applied for
biotechnology
anyway the first example is Gateway
cloning Gateway cloning is a cloning
strategy which does not involve any
restriction and location
it involves the recombinase enzymes and
site directed recombination more
specifically
so it the the site directed
recombination what we learned for phage
is utilized in Gateway cloning in this
case we can see our insert in blue and
we need to clone it in an expression
Vector so basically this particular
segment is flagged by ATT B sites and
the donor Vector has ATT P sites
so these these two sites can recombine
with each other with the help of BP
clonease enzyme and that would allow the
insert to be incorporated into the entry
clone Vector eventually the entry clone
Vector uh and a destination Vector can
be can recombine with each other with
the help of LR clones which has ATT Elsa
so these vectors has ATT L sides and ATT
R sites which again recombine with each
other ultimately giving back that ATT B
sites so ultimately in the expression
clone we can put our Gene of Interest
note that in this entire sequence we
never used a restriction digestion
strategy we use recombination which is
much more efficient compared to
restriction and ligation systems
Gateway cloning is widely used nowadays
in molecular research labs
the second system is creelock speed
system three locksby system is a
transgenic system used in Mouse or many
other organism for generation of
conditional mutants so here we have a
conventional cream house
which codes for a recombinence enzyme
which is crossed with a lock speed Mouse
so in the cream house a tissue specific
promoter would drive the expression of
tree recombinase eventually these Mouse
would be crossed with a lock speed site
containing Mouse so in this case log SP
cites a specific recombination sites
which are flanking a particular genomic
region when they are crossed together
Cree recombinants would be generated
which is a tyrosine recombinants and
Cree recombinase would flank would sit
on these Lock speed sites ultimately
based on the orientation it can either
delete it or invert it in this example
the particular site which was flanked by
logspecide is deleted and thereby three
exons are chopped off and a mutant form
of that allele is generated and this
strategy is used by the mouse geneticist
very frequently to generate conditional
mutants in the laboratory usage so now
we understand how important site
directed recombination and the principle
behind site directed recombination is
you can get more notes and flash cards
in my Facebook page follow us on
Instagram support our Channel via super
thanks see you in next video